hey everybody and welcome to a nostalgic
wild ride with stevo man can i tell you
that this is the first intro for this
podcast that i've been able to record in
this room for
months
and when i say this room of course i'm
talking about my home studio
slash edit room and it got this big
exciting makeover you know we're gonna
put a
link to the video about the makeover in
the description check it out it's
unbelievable and this podcast was such a
treat man who knew that steve urkel aka
jaleel white was going to be so much fun
to talk to
man i hope this one does as well as the
frankie muniz podcast because it's every
bit as awesome yeah dude let's get into
it
ladies and gentlemen jaleel white oh way
oh hey yeah dude said you've met scott
randolph yeah what's up
and paul briskey up front julia they
were here before you pulled up i know
dear i i ran late these guys
screwed me
hold that in a second oh see did they
give you the wrong time or something no
no i wasn't there you just left late
then he blamed it on us
you're the star i just gave you the
platform to completely blame it on these
guys you didn't take no no i i i left
late because they were calling me up
talking about we need this wire we we
don't have that
and so i'm rummaging around looking for
what these knuckleheads should have had
how's that there you go
jalen made it on time and he came from
orange county right on the dot
[Music]
where uh
and you had a prior engagement right
here at this dispensary yeah i had one
um and oc at my favorite dispensary in
oc the tropicana yeah here let's get you
right on that microphone you can pull it
towards you too you know it's weird it's
like my instincts are not to pull that
towards me
yeah yeah you know my instincts are like
well can't you just increase the button
back yeah
yeah but okay i'm gonna let it come
towards you
i'm gonna let it go yeah it's a thereza
said he's like what are you doing
holding on to this thing
you might wanna let that go
so
your favorite dispensary is it safe to
say that it's uh
people find it counter-intuitive to know
that you're
like
a dispensary selling weed and stuff
you know what i just i'm enjoying the
rebranding of what cannabis is to be
quite honest all right you know i didn't
grow up as a kid uh smoking or or any of
that stuff never even got in trouble
with the law um but but i was in my
early 30s man i went on a ski trip with
some buddies of mine at aspen and they
had some great [ __ ]
and it was just like eye-opening how
great it was and then i started doing my
research and obviously purple oracle had
been around for many many years so
people have been sending me that little
snapshot you know i was like hey man you
get paid off this you get paid off these
rounds like nope nope nope and i never
even thought to because it was just on
the other side of that fence right man
our new world is going to look so
different the cannabis industry is no
different than the wine industry man you
know all these trains are just varietals
and for the people who know what they're
shopping for you want to make sure they
get good stuff man that's really
interesting to compare the cannabis
industry to the wine industry
as opposed to
the alcohol industry in general
because
uh there's more connoisseurs in wine
like the same type of right yep
for sure i mean it makes a lot of sense
and even the landscape of the alcohol
industry in general is changing where
it's not just it's almost very similar i
think to like television where it used
to be just the networks and then just
the networks and cable but now that the
media has fragmented so much that
there's really just like anybody can get
into it stevo was crazy it was like you
know if if any of us ever really want to
really take what's going to happen in
the future seriously just look at our
kids
and my daughter doesn't watch anything
on network television right unless it's
a sporting event sure or or a live show
like like you know the oscars or golden
globes she watches youtube she watches
youtube and she watches netflix and she
watches any of the streamers that we
have um and and once they start watching
something like they'll have little
playdates dude to just binge on stuff
yeah i didn't matter of fact that there
was this program she was watching on
netflix and i think she set up a
sleepover because she wasn't sure i
would let her watch it so they been she
and his other little girl [ __ ]
she said she's got g12 going on exactly
you know
in her mind but it was just like yeah
all they care about man is youtube and
streamers right and tick tock did you
see the documentary uh series
i don't think it was netflix original
but i watched on netflix it was called
murder mountain
no i didn't is that where they have all
the like up in like
it it was it was uh
the story of
of humboldt county and its history with
uh the bootleg game for growing
marijuana
and and you know it's called murder
mountain it's called murder mountain
though uh it lives on netflix
it's on netflix and and
it's it's really pretty crazy the way it
tells the story about how you know
people would go missing and like all
this is like kind of like a
the an underbelly of crime that
surrounded like the you know the black
market marijuana industry but by the end
of the series it really turns into an
indictment of the legalization of
marijuana
to a degree because they say that
with the legalization they really
make it to get your license and and all
this and that like all the costs are
prohibitive for the small grower that
they would actually prefer it still be
illegal oh yeah actually it's
there's um
the system isn't doing the best job um
blending the black market in the legal
market
they're almost going out of their way
to harm the people who have been you
know at the forefront of the community
illegally um as opposed to ingratiating
them right saying okay look you know you
can come out of the bushes over there
right um you know and then these are all
reasonable steps that you can take to
becoming legal it's not the game is not
like that for me it was different
because i i bs you not man it really was
about legacy
and it's just kind of like he was i'm
sitting here i'm gonna be real with you
i don't get star struck too often
but when you pulled up when you walked
and walking up the streets i was like my
boy freaked and we gotta you gotta meet
him afterwards he's my friend and he was
like i had that moment too where i was
like
yo this steve oh man
thanks man like i had i had that moment
like you know it was just like i'm i'm
doing this man for legacy you know i
want i want everything associated with
what i did
um in the 90s and with tgif etc etc to
to live on in a positive way
and um i didn't create this
this this was the streets saying this is
how a section of us insurance
so when you just lean into that and you
embrace that it's like it's like
embracing your own graffiti art you know
what i'm saying i'm like i'm sorry your
building got defaced
but you know damn it's a good mural you
know right right right before the before
i went and bought some some it's purple
yeah yeah yeah
i'm sober but i wanted to support it and
so i wanted to smell it you know oh yeah
just want to smell it for the first time
on the is that damn
you can at least let them know it smells
that good it smells so damn good well
i'm sorry
and then and i really regret smelling
that because it smells so damn good like
i'm like i'm a sober guy and i don't
like to be around
no i feel you know like like
because it's too tempting yeah if people
are drinking alcohol around me that
doesn't really affect me but if people
are smoking weed i'm breathing it in oh
yeah but that's one reason why i'm not
even they told me that's why i was
smoking around
just just the whiff i i appreciate that
and i'd be the first person to tell you
steve no yeah not stephen steve no
but how do you pick what strain you want
for your
legacy so it's you know really it's
purple that's what the the actual name
of the company is um we just want to be
the best in purples so whether it's you
know old family purpose gdps you name it
um you know purple urkel was more or
less just of our our invitation to do
this um and we're just we're doing
crosses and whatever and up and up up in
our oakland facility and
um you know whatever comes out great we
we've done actual phenol hunts and uh
that was interesting it's the final hunt
is that like
like the spores right so that's where we
pop the seeds
and we get all these different plants
but we don't know what's special yet so
we just get rows and rows of plants and
then you go and you smell the plants
and like the first five plants i smelled
i turned the bread and i was just like
you know i don't think maybe i have the
nose talent for this maybe somebody else
who knows what they're doing he says no
keep going and then finally i smelled
something that smells spells
smells special
and um and he said okay cool this guy
from behind us with a clipboard he's
like write that one down so we
what we do is we go through all the
after we pop all these seeds not all
these plants are going to be good we're
looking for something special so we end
up with maybe five or six plants that
are somewhat special if you and that's a
big volume but these guys did a good job
and and then that you create a room off
of that plant
oh and you're talking about seeds not
just so wouldn't you like top uh chop
off the top of the plant and then just
okay
no i don't know if i was about to chop
it off the top of it just actual seeds
well we pop these seeds and we and we
and we and we fill up you know a large
portion of a room
so that we
can find something special right and
once you find something special then you
proceed with with with that particular
plant and
that would be your mother plant and then
how long does that take you to from from
sniff to oh man that was today that was
like um that was a four to six months
process right really yeah that really
was cause the first three months were
just about investigation and then the
the the back three months are what the
the ones that you chose i feel like i'm
throwing tommy chong under the bus
whenever
whenever i ask a marijuana like
enthusiast sure but
we were talking to tommy chong on this
podcast and i and i just said so like is
isn't it crazy or isn't it crazy how
much more powerful marijuana
is than when it was like you know when
you first got in the game back in the
70s and he says it's not he says he says
it's uh it's the same this is the same
plan nothing changed they always had
that like super
and
be real had the same reaction
i love tommy chong but the fact is that
the green stuff has become way more
powerful over the years and athletic
greens is no exception this is how i
start
every day you can see me i'm starting to
run a little low over here i scoop a
scooper of that stuff into a pint of
water to start every day to help me be
hydrated and to fill in any nutritional
gaps in my diet because hey man i don't
always eat enough greens you know also
this is super good for gut health for
digestion
and uh
if you try to take certain supplements
like first thing when you wake up taking
them on an empty stomach is no bueno but
my athletic greens and a pint of water
boom not only is it delicious but it's
totally okay on a completely empty
stomach and all this stuff is sourced
from
super
like natural healthy real food and i'm
telling you it's so delicious i've
religiously use this every single
morning and then i feel good about maybe
eating garbage for the rest of the day
not that you should eat garbage for the
rest of the day but if you do
man is it important to have your
athletic greens ag-1 in the morning plus
we've got a killer deal for you if you
go to athleticgreens.com
stevo you're going to get an entire
year's supply of immune boosting vitamin
d
plus five travel packs of ag-1 with your
first order and it's it's a killer deal
man so support the podcast support your
own health and support this great
company by going to athleticgreens.com
devo for an immune boosting year supply
vitamin d and five free travel packs of
ag-1 yeah dude i love you athletic
greens now let's talk about the other
greens
you know bless tommy chong's heart he's
the best guy but i think be real put it
pretty well yeah be real on that one
maybe his horrors is just so high that
like nothing
can penetrate i mean right i mean be
real how do you put it he said you know
it's like you know you've got uh
uh
supplements you've got you know
technologies you've got like and even
just the cross breeding and like you
know science is actually working on it
he said if you put a uh you know 2021
nfl team up against a 1970s nfl team
they would have a problem too
i don't know because it depends are we
playing by the 1970s rules are we
playing by the 2021 rules ah
i mean playing by the 1970s rules i mean
2021 that performance-enhancing drugs
that are legal
in the 70s they just had performances
cocaine and budweiser now they have
testosterone back then they had cocaine
yeah they're doing like uppers and
you know but even like dudes like smoke
on the bench and stuff they just did
unfathomable stuff done yeah yeah bruce
was like just [ __ ] up yeah oh yeah it
is i don't know if it was babe ruth
who's [ __ ] up uh like or was it mickey
mantle or is it someone like all of them
i'm just drunk but even like you have to
drink beer like in the in the freaking
clubhouse yeah that's crazy yeah michael
jordan was saying that when he joined
the bulls like they were like drinking
beers at halftime machine he's like what
are you guys doing
yeah who was that doc ellis who was the
uh the pitcher for the kitten
i don't know how much of a basketball
fan you are but a lot of people don't
don't really remember
vernon maxwell from the houston rockets
was like one of the biggest gangsters
the nfl has ever seen and i just watched
a video the other day of him arguing
with a fan and he was telling the fan
like shut the f up and um the dude and
the fan looks like he's like carbon copy
of bill gates this is carbon copy they
were calling phil gates in in the
comments
and uh and brennan just said he had
enough he just took his stuff up with
him this was deck the fan
and this is like
way before malice in the palace right
brought our tests and stephen jackson
like this dude set the table so
they can have a buffet
just jumped up in the stands pop the
dude in the nose he had to be separated
came back down sat on the bench like he
was gonna go back in the game
and then i guess there was a little
conversation was like all right vernon
you did that you gotta go
and that was yeah like can he do that i
was saying
half season suspension or nothing three
cameras it probably went on daily you
know like
oh yeah the aba was gangster though
aviated merged with the nba that was
part of the issue with the aba is that
the aba's um teams and their locations
were just far more hood but they had the
better athletes so the nba was coming
with that corporate shine and the aba
had the better athletes and that's how
that's where dr j came from oh really is
that what the the will ferrell movie was
based on yeah it was somewhat based on
that jackie moon baby
we love jackie moon yeah we
watched that one like real recent nice
yeah dude
so uh dude we were we were both on a
couple of the same tv shows i'm sure we
were tyler henry the hollywood medium yo
that dude that deep blew my mind too
that dude half me up man is that real i
mean dude like here's the thing i'll let
you go first that dude me up man i'm
very open-minded about spiritual matters
but going into the tyler henry hollywood
medium show i didn't want to look like a
chump so i came with my guard up like
trying to be like totally skeptical
trying to not look like a [ __ ] chump
on tv and like and i was just even
trying to hate on it almost mm-hmm and
he just came with yeah
what he just knew things about you that
he shouldn't know he just he knew
i didn't help this guy in any way right
so unless my manager at the time
uploaded him with in certain information
which i don't think my man did
the way he slowly broke me down because
obviously with an edit you can make it
seem like this is all happening right
you know
you know in a quicker amount a quicker
amount of time you know it took it was a
long interview right but i let him just
keep getting there and getting there and
getting there and he really like he
landed hard on my co-star man who passed
away
like he landed hard on her and it was
just like it just got to a point where i
was like i have to tell him who
he's talking about
he he landed hard for just on my family
dynamic yeah you know like with uh
my sister and my my mom you know he got
that my mom has passed and and that uh
maybe it's just like really you told me
he was like there's like a
loud room full of women wanting to talk
to you
like yeah you're you're aunts and you're
just you know
various relatives and there was like one
person it felt like it was my gran my
grandfather actually or my father
um but other than that he was just like
they're all shutting him up because they
want to talk to you
right yeah i mean it was it was pretty
pretty damn impressive man and i felt
too my takeaway watching the edited
version that came out was that
that that it didn't even do justice to
the experience that i had you know like
they that it that they actually lost
like the
the poignance of it you know like the
impact was lost in the edit as opposed
to
like beefed up right yeah so yeah dude
that was that was a big one so that one
and then what else would you guys like
we were both done dancing with the stars
oh that's so crazy as hell too
how far did you get i got seven weeks in
wow dude i got six weeks out yeah i got
seven weeks in uh they like are you any
good at dancing they like us guys in
glasses um
i was i was actually pretty good you
know i was i didn't feel like i was
terrible with it but my body was aching
like i had to take epson's whole bath
every sunday right before the show
uh why because you're training so hard i
was training so i lost how long did you
train i lost 16 out of 16 pounds doing
that show really
and uh yeah wow we train
you you know you film those they make
you feel those crazy packages more more
than you than you actually danced and so
i would get frustrated with that because
i was like you know when they're signing
you up you just think okay you're just
rehearsing all day and i just know
myself as a performer that if i rehearse
all day i'm not going to suck
like not the other way around man like
i'm i just felt
helplessly caucasian man
you know like like i don't have rhythm i
don't know how to dance and i could have
i wasn't like lazy about training but it
was painfully obvious to me that i could
train for 20 hours every day for [ __ ]
six months and i would still suck oh
yeah
there's an it factor there that you were
yeah just like my baseline and my my my
my window for potential just wasn't that
i mean look they have the show has its
ringers so it's like every every season
has two to three carlton yeah two to
three people who have like massive dance
experience yeah and for whatever reason
just people choose not to focus on it
and you know they give a great dance and
that's cool but i'm like you're going to
get ice skaters and alfonso rivero you
know apostle grew up dancing on broadway
yeah people forget that he's like i'm
not gonna let you chubby carlton this
guy out this dude was a broadway
trained
dancer yeah wasn't he like a michael
jackson impersonator as a kid
you guys were talking about he trained
michael jackson yeah right didn't you
play young michael like in a music video
yeah something like that it was i think
it was a pepsi commercial yeah okay that
famous pepsi commercial with michael
jackson so yeah
yeah dude so we're not a ringer yeah so
there was a lot of ringers though so you
can't
steve i hate to break it to you but
they they asked you on the show so you
could lose right no no of course man
they did the same thing to me
there's no doubt in my mind that that's
the case and for me at that time i had
just like come off a pretty like serious
downward spiral i was living in a
halfway house
you know about like uh
you know i
almost exactly one year into sobriety
i'd been in rehab for like heavy like
problems with drugs and stuff and they
like saw that going on they thought
because they love a good transformation
story you know like and at the time i
felt like it uh
it made sense like like you know okay
like
i don't know if uh if
you know
committing to this life of
being a guy in recovery if being an
attention [ __ ] works with that you know
like working in entertainment and now
like with all this sober stuff and
dancing with the stars was my way of
testing that to see if it could work
and i felt like it was a safe way to do
that but once i got involved in dancing
with the stars it was so stressful man
was so scary
like i sucked first of all you are
dancing in front of freaking 20 million
people every freaking monday so
you feel shot out of a freaking cannon
with adrenaline yeah right before that
[ __ ] happens and it's live and live tv
yeah and it's live so the other like one
of the things with me i i haven't talked
about this with too many people but it
was like look i know who i am i know
what my legacy is i'm really kind of an
athlete at heart so i always land on my
feet for the most part
but i knew that having playing having
played the character that i played for
so long
i just didn't want to fall
like that was my big fear i was just
like if i fall or i look like a klutz in
any way
it could have been an honest athlete
moment where you just fell or whatever
but for me that was going to be did i do
that no it was just like and it was just
like having that pressure dancing every
week that was tough and it probably i
had my most fun week one
but then week five i got my joy back
again because i went to train with kim
in new york and so we were away from
everybody so we kind of just kind of
landed off the plane with our dance and
i hadn't been in the the the
you know the crap the media crap all
week because they follow you around
differently yeah you know you know
the tablet guys they don't chase me they
looking for kardashians and [ __ ] you
know they but that week or when i was on
the show oh
you know tabloid dudes are following you
around all over town yeah i didn't stand
up in front of 1500 people last week my
heart rate went to 170.
dancing in front of 20 million people
i'd just be like you'd pass out and it
died it's gnarly yeah it's gnarly i
remember like i was laying in my little
halfway house bed the night before the
premiere and i was like i can't take it
i can't take it i got to back out like i
was having like a panic attack and it
occurred to me then and ever since that
i can't believe that in all the seasons
of dancing with the stars that nobody
didn't back out it was too much pressure
and that and then on the premiere
there's people that have backed out they
just don't frame it that way everything
is a story line right right right this
person got injured or whatever right
like oh yeah i bet that that makes more
sense oh yeah no everything is
everything is a story and it was like i
hate to say it but it was like if you
did have some you know catastrophic fall
or did some lift and dropped her and she
fell on your head it would be on camera
because they filmed everything they
actually
they loved that they called that this
was the phrase i got from doing the show
they call that good tv
that's my life sprawled out on the floor
right there you call it good tv holy
[ __ ] yeah but the people there are great
man i really did you
after after your experience on dancing
did you ever go back to be in the
audience yeah just like yeah i actually
went to visit uh calvin johnson the uh
megatron he was on the show and
apparently he grew up being a big fan of
mine so one of his dances he dressed up
as my old character cool so um they
asked me to pop by and uh even when you
you're coming you know you're coming
through the back you know and then the
other dancers are you know val and
whatever really hey yeah yeah yeah you
know it's it's a special fraternity to
be a part it is it's
not gonna sugarcoat the show is
difficult because they tell you you're
gonna get to rehearse this much and you
don't get to rehearse that much but it
is a lot it's just not enough
in five days to pick up an entire style
and choreography and that's what they
want they want you to feel the stress of
it [ __ ] that yeah yeah i mean there's
definitely it's definitely a pressure
cooker yeah
you um
you have such a good relationship with
like steve urkel the character yeah was
there ever like resentment towards this
character that like people see you so
much as urkel were you ever like oh [ __ ]
steve urkel or have you always been like
cool with it it's tough because um hey
i've always gotten mad positivity from
people about it
so i really can't only react to the way
to the streets
um at the executive level i think there
were definitely some uh you know certain
issues um but i think it really wasn't
about that wasn't about urkel
so i always like to kind of clarify that
with people i think that was just about
tgif
so what's cjm well tgif was the name of
the entire lineup
and there's like how many shows were on
that it was it was us it was step by
step
exactly gods and so i just feel like
that was the beginning really of like
being branded
as an actor
and where brands were just kind of
jumping out like crazy like george
clooney used to play basketball with me
all the time and george is a great guy
because they filmed er right next door
to us
but we're so branded differently you
probably couldn't even imagine and other
people like what he played basketball
with george clooney as a kid it was like
yeah
we're right next door to each other was
there a basketball court there or were
you guys just bros enough to go find one
so this was so this was so funny
george was the one that taught me about
about star power
when i first got onto the show
they had um they erected a basketball
set for me in the alleys between two
stages
and that i played on that on that
basketball hoop my entire childhood and
then one day a teamster came over and
asked me if he could move the um the
hoop out into a a more common area that
was uh between our set and er's and i
was just he asked me personally i was
like yeah oh yeah no it's cool man i've
been there for three years in that one
spot four years
and um
and then um slowly but surely i would
hear people around the lot saying oh
george clooney's basketball hoop oh over
at george clooney's bathroom
and you know george was on his way to
becoming the peacemaker now and and
batman and the superstar and so suddenly
it was like i know that was that was
mine i said it was okay if they moved it
out there yeah i give george permission
so we had some great we had some great
battles on there but when i but going
back to wrapping up my point though
about that whole like tgif thing was it
was just like you know there was an era
when office hit big right after the
friends era where it was like anything
on network television had to had to have
that like single camera feel
and uh you know multicams and sitcoms
were just not in they weren't cool so
anybody that came from a tgif show
was just thought to be not a serious
enough actor
and we had to get past that phase
and i started doing a lot of dramas as a
matter of fact i was on every show there
was man if you go back and check man i
did castle i did bones i did i did
boston legal i was just like i don't
even care what they want me to say man i
just want people to understand acting is
acting it doesn't have anything to do
with sticking people in these mediums
like that's the sitcom guy and this is
the dramatic actor it's like nah as
actors we look at each other and we know
who can go you know it's just about
whether or not you're going to get that
opportunity like i there's a kid right
now just throw it out there because i
know it uh elijah kelly um and uh and he
just got cast in the road to play sammy
davis jr um and i remember i just told a
friend i was like if elijah got cast to
play sammy davis jr he's going to take
off he's going to take off like a rocket
i remember i was in atlanta when
somebody a friend of mine told me jamie
foxx was going to play uh ray charles
and i'm like i know jamie skill set i
knew it was going to be big i didn't
know it was going to be oscar big but i
remember when he told me i was just like
oh yeah jamie don't kill that dog yeah
he's gonna impersonate anybody and also
he's a song man
so
you know the kid who played uh freddie
mercury yep oh crushed that role god
crushed it and he's the same guy from uh
the the one tv show with kevin uh
christian slater uh mr robot yeah yeah
yeah
yep yep yep then
we moved and what was your take on the
kid who did elton john just didn't look
like elton john man the rocket man movie
i didn't see that one though i didn't
see that i think that kid's a great
actor i mean i saw the freddie mercury
story because right right so stupid i
had to i had to check that out stupid is
a good thing let's do it right right
right yeah but
sorry
you go i was curious because uh we had
jodie sweetin on yeah yeah
you know tgif family yeah were you guys
competitive
per show like i have more ratings or you
have more ratings or were you guys all
tight and cool because it's a weird tgif
yeah weird nah we were
we were all tight and cool as kids
matter of fact my my counterpart really
was candace cameron you know candace and
i grew up like that
um and so jody would always be on the
set when i saw her so obviously it was a
big difference when i was here at the
clubs later on when we were for sure
yeah we talked about that
she had grown
yeah
her episode of our podcast dirty sweden
crushed it like out of nowhere like jody
was in the street style joshua said if
she couldn't even believe that but i
love how honest she is about it now and
i love that yeah the cast
the cast really came together man
and and really saved her up you know
they lifted her up you know yeah with
fuller house that was a lot of that was
about jody as a matter of fact
jody out who had the most views on tgif
um was that you guys so that was gonna
boil down to time slots let's go to
bingo
yo my man is like she's people
um yeah that's gonna come down to time
slot when we first started full house
was our lead in and then they got moved
to tuesday ah
if we had gotten moved to tuesday
i it's scary the numbers that we could
have gotten friday is actually a pretty
[ __ ] day for for um yeah because people
got each
stuff to do so on you know aaron on
fridays uh it was amazing that we even
became a top 20 show uh airing on friday
nights how many views is that like uh 20
million well the views change back so
back then um it it might have been that
because it was i just remember the
points the nielsen points would be like
you know
when we first started it would be like
18 and 19 which is close to 20. that's
crazy man right by the time we went off
the air they were down to like nines and
eights
i just remember those numbers and now i
look at these numbers as like one point
three one point right
it's it's i don't understand how the
system is still standing on itself to be
quite i don't get it either man i really
don't i don't because
in general
i don't get it i think the answer is
that everybody's doing like uh in
conjunction with the streaming platform
and a subscription service that's what's
what's been propping it up especially
considering the fact that i have a 12
year old daughter in my house who does
not watch a single show on network
television i'm like what is right what
is fueling this yeah i called my nieces
and nephew on facetime and they were
watching carter was that the guy i was
in the green room in dc oh yeah
oh carter they were freaking out over
this guy and i'm like you you guys watch
that they're like oh my god they're
obsessed
that's crazy do you have a youtube
channel any [ __ ] like that dude i'm
terrible i got to start one this year
yeah you got any tips for me just
anything that anybody ever wants to do
my tip is to start doing it
don't wait for the but i mean like
don't make this mistake on youtube okay
this is the kind of content that they
really really love i mean what i see out
of you the beauty of youtube is that
that you can just take a trial and error
approach you can throw it
throw [ __ ] at the wall and then go with
what sticks
um i think that the best advice for for
me is to uh get yourself an editor you
know first start out by by writing a
list of uh
of subjects like for for videos you know
like just ideas for videos make a whole
list and then just knock them out one by
one and what's great is that on youtube
you can
um
you can you can really uh
put what's called fair usage law to to
work you know like um you see what i
just did yeah
if you uh like if you want to see if you
want to tell the story of your career
you can go ahead and include footage
from family matters okay and and as long
as you're telling a story you're not
just like
you know putting it like if you're
using it to illustrate a story and make
points then you have the right to use
that footage so
see that was helpful fair usage live
even like reacting to like i haven't i
put jackass stuff all everything
everything you know if i want to tell a
story like i can put up a video
you know my 10 best jackass bits and
because i'm telling you about them likes
like new information like i'm allowed to
do it nice you can talk about being the
voice of sonic the hedgehog yes
yes my side hustle that has followed me
for like freaking 20 years crazy yeah
you do any other voice over work or i i
did um i've done a lot of voice over
work even with total blackout uh was the
show that i used to host i actually got
that gig from stanford's dancing with
the stars we used to put people in pitch
black darkness uh for time challenges
and it was on sci-fi network dog it was
one of the coolest jobs i've ever had
but they used to have me talking to the
people in the darkness and at the same
time and then they discovered we were
married to that audio yeah so instead
they had another guy who actually
created the game talk to the contestants
and then afterwards after they put the
edit together
um i would go into the booth and i would
just say whatever came to my mind
um
and and
i would whatever he had said to our our
game creator i would put in an ad-lib
and so it made it seem like i was there
but i loved that process so that was
another form of just kind of like voice
over work vo is kind of the best work
right vr work is great it pays the best
what about that that's changed that's
changed that's [ __ ] but i will say
you know when you consider
when you consider um
earned income yeah how much time
somebody's taking from you what you have
to go do the compensation and the
gratification because the other thing
too is you get do-overs you're in the
freaking booth you can do as many times
as you want sure and you do it until you
get it right
with my type personality i'll do it 20
times 30 times i don't care i just want
to hear the best one right and then
that's the one we're going to use
that's cool that would be steve steve
like we'll record like a narration to
something and it's like each sentence
it's like a hundred times
there it is there it is hey you're just
you know
you're perfectionist
yeah even in what looked like madness to
other people i'm sure you were
perfectionist
i got a question to ask you this
question
what is your pain tolerance dog oh it's
not anything special i don't think i
mean
are you are you saying that with a
straight face to me well yeah because
it's you are stevo you telling me you're
based
but when i'm in pain you see the
reaction if i didn't feel the pain there
wouldn't be a reaction and it wouldn't
be
the in the entertainment you know it
would be good tv right but you know if i
wasn't scared if i wasn't feeling the
pain
there wouldn't be a reaction and i think
that
it's not my pain
tolerance which sets me aside it's
uh
just how much of an attention [ __ ] i
really am that i'm willing to put myself
into that
situation that's why but i wouldn't say
it's an intention because when you got
those third degree burns you were still
working and that was the worst pain
you've ever been in your life yeah i
would have been day one i would day zero
hour one i would have been in the
hospital
we went to do a show he did two or three
shows stand up he's typing on the
computers like ah
just typing this is before going to get
uh emergency skin graft surgery and the
doctor's like how long have you been
like this for and he's like five days
and they're like you have to have
emergency surgery now how would you how
are you sleeping at night how are you
even sleeping yeah it was tough man that
that was a tough one yeah that that's
real tough so you sleep six hours eight
hours four yeah i don't know the best
sleep of his life
i don't know about any of that i mean
and yeah i definitely haven't you know
put gone through pain like as a sober
guy i've never uh filled a prescription
for painkillers
so like with tylenol and advil i've
gotten through all kinds of post-surgery
[ __ ] yeah no dog you gotta you you got a
different tolerance bro you i think
there is a tolerance there perhaps
probably probably not as big as most
people would think not like it doesn't
hurt twist your nipple right now you're
really eating oh dude
[Applause]
at the meet
i couldn't believe it and his reaction
did it was
why would somebody do that to you in
life
though because when they're coming to
see you what i've discovered is a lot of
people it's still about them i remember
i was at i was at a comic-con and um and
we were kind of setting up things with
the organizers and all of a sudden the
rope stanchions just crashed and this
dude falls over them and he's tangled up
in them and it they're spilling it's
just a horrible you know
and to describe it because we all did
this did you ever hop over the ropes
when in in the bank when you were a kid
with your and then and they your mom
would warn you too because it's the
loudest nastiest noise and it's just
like who is this jackass right doing
this right this guy is a grown man
it's caught up in the ropes like this
and he's on the ground and we all stop
and look at him and the dude is just
like
did i do that
yeah
remember what do you mean the ropes this
[ __ ] did this on purpose
this was just to say that he just
freaking stopped
it was like he's gonna be standing there
and then okay the ropes will be right
there i'll crash into them everybody
will look at me and it was like we gave
him that moment
and insecurity he's like yeah okay
get him out of here but it was like it
wasn't about meeting me it was about
that moment that he had dreamt of so
even that dude it was just like yeah
that's he could say you're lying yeah
exactly that dude was like it was his
mom he's like i'm gonna meet steve i'm
gonna twist his titty yeah i mean how
sick of hearing that were you like in
the 90s and 2000s i mean are you cool
with it now i'm i'm cool with it dawg
because i mean you know what it was
really for me i'm a father dog and it's
like once you have once you have kids
it's just a real big eye-opener this
[ __ ] ain't about you
so so just like i'm sitting here i'm
able to identify even this circumstance
where i'm like
i'm constantly looking for
the fan where i'm like uh
you're meeting me but this ain't about
me this is you the chance for you now to
tell me how my character helped you when
you were getting bullied in school etc
etc and like that's a real near and dear
story i'm not mocking it for that person
but when they start to tell me that
story is like dude i'm just meeting you
like i don't
i can't identify with any bullying you
you you win right right right but having
that moment to share that with me
that's the moment for them another part
of their healing or another part of that
you see what i'm saying like i'm
actually face to face with the guy that
i did draw inspiration from so you know
you kind of got to be extra graceful
sure
in relation i'm curious about something
did you see colin kaepernick's show that
he did on netflix i heard about it
he does this kind of like
yeah critique
you know that
carlton and urkel
are these like white washed black
characters yeah it's kind of like
[Music]
just like all negative the way at least
he's approaching it did you have a
reaction to that i wasn't aware of any
colin kaepernick controversy but i can
tell you i personally had a very bad
reaction to being on my last trip on
tour without the charger for my woop
band i mean dude this was heartbreaking
for me that man i got no insight into my
sleep my recovery the calories i was
burning my activity output i mean dude i
really came to learn just how much i
love my woop band when i had to live
without it on that trip man but now that
i'm back home and i got it charged up
here i am looks like i got some good
sleep last night 96
recovery
i just love to know what's going on with
my body and you know what else they've
got this new whoop 4.0 coming out where
the charger is completely waterproof i
mean dude i can't wait to get that and
you can sign up for it right now plus if
you're already a woot member and you've
got six months left on your uh on your
membership or more then
boom you can activate it you can get
that banned 4.0 for free
and if you're new to the program then
good news you can get 15
off your membership by going to woop.com
and using the promo code stevo i mean
that's 15 off at checkout and i'm
telling you once you have it you never
want to live without it because it is
the most sophisticated
epic fitness tracking device and app
out there nothing can touch whoop
anybody is serious about their health
and their fitness is gonna be wearing
one because i said so so head on over to
whoop.com use the promo code stevo check
out for 15
off
and boom let's talk about this
controversy
um
i think he's just concerned about being
famous at this point
so
you know i don't really say other
people's names i don't let other
people's names come out of my mouth
unless i
do have a extreme personal beef with
them sure so that list is extremely
short sure um um if i do say somebody
else's name i generally want to say
something positive to big up them so
when somebody and i met him before
actually
so and it was a totally cool meeting you
know um
dapped up photo benefit photo's still on
my instagram i was like i don't need to
go back and highlight it now though so
when somebody does that it's just more
or less like
i think it was kind of like dialogue
maybe that was stuck in his mouth i
wonder
[Music]
um it was really just dialogue stuck in
his mouth and when your primary concern
is just being famous at this point
then you're not thinking about who else
you're affecting with with those with
those words you know what i'm saying but
you got to kind of just take it with a
game it's getting a great assault i'm
not even familiar with the uh the whole
thing but it sounds
sounds [ __ ] up too it was sort of just
like purposefully [ __ ] up
yeah it was it wasn't
[ __ ] up i'm just saying i got a
daughter
i did like the show but that was one of
the few things i was like that was like
aggressive and kind of
not not really fair you know it was just
it was it was a little too academic for
him it was like hey bro you're not that
deep
right right like yeah if you want to be
a college professor and go ahead and
support that with you know 10 more
minutes uh go ahead and do that but
that's
your backup quarterback yeah yeah don't
do that uh-huh
yeah it lacked a lot of nuance and yeah
it just felt very great
but at the same time i was like i'm not
trying to start a beef even right there
sure now it's like
you know
there's degrees to understand so you're
you're a vet so there's degrees to
understanding in this business you know
just simple sound bites what directions
they can take you mm-hmm you know what
i'm saying and that's why i was like you
would i would just i would hope that he
understands hey man when you mention
somebody else's name of fame in this
town
it should be in a positive manner
otherwise the clickbait people are going
to do what they do and they made sure i
saw it after my morning donut
right okay so speaking about mentioning
other people's names
in a positive way
but what's your relationship with with
mike tyson oh i'm cool with mike that's
my boy i [ __ ] with mike dog mike and i
set it off for 4 20 this past year man
oh man mike is great i used to run into
mike all the time too even arsenio hall
show because he would just stop by at
the green room a lot i got bumped a
little bit for him you know where they
tell you you're going to go on third
down because this guy's sure
man you know it's mike tyson yeah um and
um but mike's man i just i love
you know how mike has just
been able to evolve you know and the
thing about mike though that i love
though is that you'll get that dude
every now and then who starts to get
real comfortable around him and they
forget hey man he's a killer
like if you anger him yeah he will f you
up
yeah right there's that on his podcast
he was talking to some dude and the guy
you know yeah
and i'm like i'm dying did that footage
ever come out yeah duh right when he
actually socks him oh he did yeah well
so the footage didn't come out
he felt like it happened but he felt
like i think he's gonna he's gonna hit
that you know what i'm talking about
he's like hey how do you know me you
don't know
you don't know what you're talking about
yep i'm so glad that wasn't me because i
would have just got up and left the
guy's a killer dog that moment i and i
know exactly what interview you're
talking about you can see his face he's
like oh [ __ ] i'm crazy yeah but it was
like but it was like it was oh [ __ ] the
cameras were rolling yeah it wasn't uh
you don't really feel that way yeah
exactly was like no i really do feel
that way and you're in danger
yeah i don't think i saw it i read about
it on tmz and i was like oh [ __ ]
i never saw it either who was like i
don't remember who the guest was those
two dudes and then the one guy mike was
like you know sometimes i feel like a
piece of [ __ ] he's not no you don't he's
like what the [ __ ] are you telling and
then like it just changed it got dark
fat and the guy was just like yeah
dude see what i'm messing with mike it
was funny i did it i did a
wee mass program with mike on 420 and it
was me
uh him this beautiful woman chef nicki
today chappelle's a private chef and um
and too short
and so you can man this is a fun meal
man yeah yeah and uh and and so she was
cooking up some fishing fish and grits
and she put the fish and grits in front
of mike and he took a bite and he was
like
this just tastes like [ __ ]
and he just starts insulting the [ __ ]
food
right there with the chef in front of
the right and two sean and i are
cracking up right but you could just
tell he's kind of going off on his tent
he's like this tastes like my actual
[ __ ]
it's just he keeps going with it like it
just keeps getting darker and darker
right but it's like i'm you know a smart
person yo this is mike tyson he's
talking about his actual [ __ ] in
reference to some freaking creamy grits
right here you're gonna let him do that
you're not gonna correct him
you're not gonna try to get it back on
course
he was like yo it was
a show idea he was like man we need to
start a show called eating with bullies
where chefs just like take their food
onto a show with a dude who could
absolutely kill them
[Laughter]
yeah we had a great time with that sure
we gonna make that show man eating with
bullies man we gonna make that show
so are you where you living at now are
you still are you you're on the west
side yeah i'm still on the west side man
once i went to ucla i got spoiled by
that weather in that side of town you
don't want to go past the 405. i i
didn't want to go back to the smog
checks in pasadena man i did those one
of those days and they would cancel
recess because it was too much small
game yeah oh [ __ ] really yeah smart guys
smog days man [ __ ] dude can i ask what's
what's the story with your watch is that
thing just badass oh no this is just a
random ass watch dog honestly i think it
was a gift to somebody it's not even now
now you're making me feel like i'm like
it looks cool i don't even think drake
would put on this watch
i don't even think he would wear this
[ __ ] this is definitely not rick russell
this is not really
that's sad so
i'm dying to know
like
from
all the network tv money you know like
that that's your family matters went on
for how many seasons man it was like
612. we did 215 episodes we did nine
seasons and we went off the air in 1998
so we got some serious anniversaries
coming up man yeah right oh yeah um
because when back then the network tv
money was was meaningful oh stupid you
know and so you got that piling up yeah
we were just talking to frankie muniz
yeah and uh he was really smart with his
money oh yeah frankie
he's [ __ ] buying park parking lots
and [ __ ]
so uh
i mean
it's it's a [ __ ] question and don't
and then feel free to feel free to tell
me so but did you
did you stack that money up properly and
did you take care of it
my dad was really into stocks so i was
really i was really lucky in that way
and we were also able to do some really
cool things in real estate um in uh the
san diego area and uh
in the vegas area um i also owned a few
homes in the palisades for a while um so
i was able to always keep flipping
things like that through my parents
believe it or not
but more importantly i'm a part owner in
the show so wow that was that was the
rarity for family matters with me is
that they did make me a part owner in
the show were you the only part owner or
were a lot more people part owner part
no
[Laughter]
whoa he just looked at me like
you know so it's like sometimes you know
you you got a raw deal in certain areas
and um i do look back on it and i know
that that
if uh
diversity issues back then had been
different um yes i would it could have
been an even sweeter deal but i will
always be grateful for the partial
ownership that i do have in the show
it has
definitely uh so so it's uh gone on and
like with syndication like uh and we
never could and the thing was we never
could have known that it would pay it
would pay out the way it did
because
if you think about it there were a
million popular shows back then though
give me everything from drew carey to
baywatch
exactly
you don't know
10 20
30 years from now what's going to emerge
as the brady bunch type show right that
just goes on forever so scooby-doo just
generation or whatever and that's like
that i'm more like scooby-doo than i am
you know it's crazy that you know the
cosby show will never air again probably
right and family matters is still
running you couldn't have told me right
that was what what you know that's that
was going to be so i always like to feel
for people like oh this person is really
smart with their money and this daniel
was like look man god has us all on
individual journeys and you know you
just got to get lucky sometimes yeah i
dig that you know what i'm saying and
you got to know you know i've had times
when i've had it good i've had times
really good i've had times where it was
like okay i'm just kind of making a
doctor's living this year um but um but
yeah that part ownership has been a
really a real saving grace and did you
own the character too like lunch boxes
and [ __ ] because urkel was on everything
yeah so it's like it's really weird when
it comes to the ownership of the
character because it's like
no talent deal was ever um extracted
from the original property
and then i i unfortunately a lot of my
um my e-commerce is bootleg
and so you know warner brothers never
defended that so that was really one of
the one of the things also that really
really inspired me to
um to build its purple because i just
wanted some images out there that were
owned by me and protected by me
yeah i mean it's clear that you're being
careful about copyright by just calling
it it's purple yeah well that well no
actually it's purple everything i do is
about a story
so it's purple really it's about um a
wanting to be the best in the purple
spectrum okay you know on for for all
purples but also when people will see me
in the streets they would be like on the
low they'd be like hey dude it's circle
and they do that crap like as if i can't
see them they're very transparent to me
and so i always just wanted something
cool to say back one day and so it's
like no it's purple
and it's like that's that that's so that
was like the hook the story of something
i've lived my entire life of people
recognizing me not so discreetly but
thinking so sure but purple oracle the
strain is just public domain anybody's
any if they make it like a cab or like i
said the wine industry anybody can you
can make whatever cab you want but you
still got to brand it
it's so crazy i i was we're both from
pasadena
i was pitching at hamilton park
hey i was on the mound and i and i heard
in the dugout somebody goes
urkel's here
50 people ran to the basketball court to
see you while i was playing the game
hilarious that's crazy i mean that's
like the 90s like you were mad i mean
the biggest you could possibly be yeah
that was that was that must have been a
crazy time you know you know the thing
that i miss the most really is just
life without cell phones yeah yeah i
could believe that like it and when you
say that it was just like
i don't mean to denigrate the current
time but just
we were just more present bro
and and we didn't have these cheat codes
either to like
meet each other you know if right if
some you know
if some social climber girl was in the
room she couldn't just get your name
look you up see if you're a big deal guy
and move on to the next one without ever
saying hi to you or anything you know
what i'm saying and the same thing even
with a girl it's like you know it's it
already takes enough it already takes
enough courage to walk up to a bad one
and be like i'm shooting my shot right
try walking up to her you know she's got
30 million followers right right it's a
daunting time right i mean it's it's a
you got to be a pretty special dude to
have zero social media following and and
and walk up to that chick you know what
i'm saying everybody's just too
available for everybody yeah it's it's
there's there's so much information out
there the lurking that we do on each
other you know even when you drop people
are dropping there
just organizing play dates between
parents the parents are all googling
each other freaking you know five and
six pages deep you know and so by the
time they even open the door to act like
they're meeting you
they've already met you right right
it's crazy but i i i i'm sober too i
reached out to one of my sponsors and i
was like oh yeah i looked up my
ex-girlfriend you know and he's like
don't do that and i was like he's like
that's stalking i'm like that's not
stalking i just look he's like what's
the difference you're looking at her and
she just has no idea like you're
stalking
i had to get out of that habit it's a
terrible habit it makes breakups hard
you know what i'm saying it was like you
know my breakups man in my 20s were so
much easier and quite frankly i was
almost
happy when i found out that somebody who
i wasn't with was married and had a kid
or whatever it was like oh man you know
what she made that step man good for her
you know what's the guy do if you saw a
picture you know now it's almost like
you know people are lurking on each
other be like i hope that [ __ ] had
happier than me
or like your friend breaks up with
somebody like do i gotta like unfollow
them now or like happen
used to be like all right i won't see
them anymore because my friend broke up
with them but now it's like i'm i'm
still following you dude listen right
look
2020 was a tough year but i was like i
remember on one of my ex's pages i was
like looking at her and i was like
looking at the page and like one of my
close boys who i like go hiking with is
like leaving comments
like staying in touch
that's weird you know what i was just
like i damn didn't want to confront him
about this [ __ ] but i'm like well let's
just wait and see if he does it again
when you're setting a play date for your
daughter
is it uh
is anybody ever like hey man we don't
know dude you're in the weed game
hilarious oh no i'm telling you bro it's
it's a new day um you know i'm a
responsible parent about it anyway you
know it's uh i went drinking wine so i
mean i'm gonna keep bringing it back to
wine uh you know it's all about you know
everything's about context now and so
people really understand it's a it's
it's a burgeoning business man there's
gonna be a great fourth of july
celebration in this country one day
once it goes federal
what uh
how far out do you see it going federal
uh you know i don't wanna i don't wanna
jinx anything but i
i we may not make it out of this decade
i mean yeah what do you call it uh
the uh the the point where the tipping
point uh the critical mass
point of critical seven percent dude
freaking seth and conan
smoked
on conan's like last show
on basic cable uh-huh lit it up and you
were saying that what got you in the
game is you saw leonardo dicaprio with a
vape pen on nbc and you're like nobody's
saying anything bro i was i was sitting
on my couch leo's sitting there i mean i
got mad respect for leo anyway because
people don't really respect him for
being an og child actor leo growing
pains everything right so i'm like
gilbert great yeah so i know leo's path
leo's just a guy that got branded
beautiful and he's a good looking dude
but he was always a hardcore character
actor like this dude gets into character
yeah and uh so but you know he and his
crew they get after it and so you know
i'm watching the freaking golden globes
that's crazy
[Applause]
yeah no i gotta build my brand b i gotta
build my brain
your 12 year old daughter yeah
all of a sudden she says hey dad let me
get some of that purple [ __ ]
she already rocks the hoodie i mean
you got to look at it the same way as as
like you know snoop's kids you know he's
probably got the best litmus test of
somebody growing up in a stoner's
household you know and
calvin to be his i mean
his youngest son is
all of his sons they're they're amazing
they're entrepreneurs they're all over
the place they're they've got they've
got their own booths and complex guns
and they said his daughter
uh his wife i mean they couldn't be a
more picture-perfect american family you
know it's i'm telling you man like a
football coach yeah he's a freaking
football coach he's got snoop's chargers
i mean i'm like you
you know i think that branding is
dangerous man cause it can make you give
a perception about something that that
was wrong it was always right i mean i
think the conventional wisdom would be
that hey that's not cool you know but
but there's a lot to be said for just
being upfront with it communicating
about it and not like sweeping anything
under the brush they're not gonna be
some i'm dude my daughter's gonna drink
far before she's 21. okay she's going to
be
16 17 18 years old with me and if we
wanted to taste some wine i mean that's
ordinary in france she's going to taste
some wine sure you know what happens is
i i think and you can educate me about
this i think when things are made too
taboo yeah that's one of the reasons why
where abuses can come from um as opposed
as as opposed to
you know
um um and that's just one of the places
you know because people have again
we're all battling our own demons you
know what i'm saying but i'm like i
don't want to make anything with my
daughter taboo my daughter educated me
the other day when she was like oh yeah
um
um she was talking about one of her
girlfriends she's like yeah she's a
pansexual and i'm just like
what and me and my girlfriend are both
we hitting the googles real quick
whatever
my daughter's just just killed casually
i'm like okay
tell us about this and she told us what
super straight is i guess super straight
is a bad thing now what is that because
well super straight means you're
straight
but the the the um
the implication is that you're
you're super straight you're not
tolerant of of uh
of other people right so you would think
in your mind from our generation oh i'm
super straight yeah no i'm super sweaty
he's like homophobic
no no no no no super straight means you
have you're so much being like super
white or something yeah
like whatever they called with the
white like white power yeah i mean
whatever like it sort of thinks things
it's uh straight power
but it was like
yeah and i get what you're saying with
it it's like you know power to the
straight people yeah
but it was like yeah she gave her like
six different freaking orientations and
and she's in the seventh grade and it's
just like a non-issue for her it's like
it's the future's gonna be different
stop looking at
through the lens of somebody who really
was told what to do with their life in
the 80s and the 90s that's great yeah
yeah it's definitely a wild time
i lost my trend of thought it got deep
because i was thinking about something
no oh i don't wait i got a random
question was uh married with children
going on at the same time yeah
i knew faustino
come on man
i was real clever with this money yeah i
knew philosophy didn't pasta you know
but faustino was a fun dude he always
had hot chocolate hot cars
why do you say he's good with his money
you know i
knew him a little bit uh
for a while back and
i got that impression that he i don't
know his merrill lynch portfolio i just
know you're happy because in hot cars
back then yeah yeah but was having a
good time yeah
fox might have something to say about
that that's possible my issues are clear
but fox might have something to say
about that
stay away from burn buddy
bud
so so you're just going around today
making appearances at the different
stores yeah man it's like
you know
i'm really passionate about it man like
i love interacting with the customer i
love talking to the bud tenders uh
because our quality is so good you saw
his reaction video quality is so
freaking good and what happens is just
keep it real most people are like all
right another celebrity trying to sell
us tequila or weed or whatever right it
was like
the way to differentiate yourself with
that is you know work your butt off man
and get in get in a partnership with
somebody who cares about quality and
packaging and all that good stuff and
then the customer just turns right there
in front of you like is that 710 labs
exactly it was like oh this is not a
gimmick it's like no bruh i want to sell
more perp than any brother in this
country
all right you will
yeah that's good that's good
is it is there any comparison
to sex because this has crossed my mind
how
bob saget you got this image of him from
the whole house that's why tgif but then
but then it turns out that in his comedy
the dude's bluer than hell he's a
[ __ ] raunchy ass guy
and it it it takes people for
for a loop and so then is is there any
comparison to you where you've got this
image and then oh but you're the
dispensary cat listen man we almost had
an epic we almost had an epic event take
place uh dave chappelle
flew
me
sagat dang cook lunell
it was like a whole plane full of
comedians during the pandemic for his
comedy deal to his uh to his summer camp
ohio i went multiple times actually it
was it was dave and elaine did you do
stand up i don't do stand-up yet i i'm
waiting until my child support days are
done
and i think i might have some material
yeah but um but dude it was me and
saggitt on the plane and they were gonna
do a full house team versus family
matters team of kickball
okay and the bubble broke that weekend
like somebody got covered oh got it and
we all had to just you know and this is
like it was going down so like if you
had kovid it wasn't just the cooties it
was you know it was like an aids
announcement
right exactly it was it was a total
scarlet letter yeah nobody wanted to be
around you yeah somebody yeah it was it
was freaking crazy you could tell me
right now like oh i just had it two days
ago and i'd be like really was your arm
sword no wait a minute i'm sorry uh
where did you get the chills yeah yeah
yeah right
but uh but yeah that was gonna be an
epic event second is dirty damn dirty we
have a plane man it's just you know i
don't i don't take it there necessarily
i'm sure of course i almost kind of wish
for his sake
that he had been able to
um
you know kind of like transition
from a little bit dirty before you just
go full dirty on them because it's
really it's it's jarring yeah you know
and it's like i would sit in the
audience
and and he doesn't hold back like you
know bob's bob and and i i love him for
it
but it's like
i love comedy on it on on a deep level i
love comedy like you know we would
pre-appreciate this bud you know what
i'm saying we're like i know the good of
it and i know the bad of it yeah and so
i know when it's getting rough when it's
getting rocky and uh
you know and i also know when it's
special and just coming out of the gate
he rides that line
he rides
he's going full tracy morgan yeah
yeah but he still has people like we
were at the comedy works in colorado and
they're like we had sagging here and
some lady like walked out because she
was like offended yeah it's like you
still don't know at this point like he's
not danny who he is when you're buying
that ticket like he still has people
like right oh this isn't what i expected
right yeah and i wasn't suggesting that
you i was just saying which is with the
weed
you know the the weed tie-in that it's
like oh you know it's uh
i'm telling you it's just it's a new day
and age
i'm trying to learn about these nfts man
well you gonna make us nft man what are
we yeah
and nft i sold one of them you sold
you've already sold one
again i'm too far behind in life you
could do one that says did i do that and
then like sell that as an instead of go
i wonder if there's any copyright
appreciations to that oh maybe because
you know west coast wanted to nft her
laugh and like people were asking her to
do that i don't think he can copyright
somebody's laugh i mean copyright's
gonna be a question you gotta be able to
own whatever it is you're selling my
understanding yeah but uh you know when
nfts came out on the scene
you're hearing about uh you know logan
paul made five million bucks and one day
you know i was selling nfts and i'm like
all these numbers flying around i
thought i have to do this and uh i i
sold one for like three grand which is
nothing to sneeze at three grand is
great but compared to the numbers that
i've been seeing floating around i i was
a little less excited with the
experience than with the idea
i want to start buying weed
wheat shops in the metaverse are you do
you know anything about that i mean
people are buying like
[ __ ] blocks in new york on the
metaverse and they're like it's
equivalent to people
uh
buying saks fifth avenue like the fifth
street in new york in the nineteen
hundreds like because
okay i have a real i don't even know i
have a real ignorant question and i have
been busy so give me you know give me a
pass all right
with my dad i got i got a lot of
household responsibilities he [ __ ] the
metaphors no i i know what the metaverse
is but how the [ __ ] you get into it like
i cannot even understand cryptocurrency
so i damn well don't even have a [ __ ]
handle on the message
player one ready ready player or
whatever
and i think that's what it is okay but
i'm saying i'm like
is there
i i get that but
but i think it's like it's like going on
instagram either but it's like but it's
like when i go to fifth avenue on google
earth right they're not selling me that
i'm looking at it on google earth yeah
that's different why is it when i put on
my oculus fifth avenue now has a price
tag because you're gonna look down you
can see you can wear nikes and it's not
just your feet it's like you got the
dope
i just spit that out
but if you take it but
but if you like take your your headset
off and now it's time to get down with
the chick and you can't you now you're
not wearing nikes you're wearing mikeys
right yeah i know are you still cool to
her that you had not you had nikes in in
the metaverse yeah no if you meet a girl
in the metaverse yeah she never wants to
meet you in real life
and also like are you interacting with
the person side by side in the metaverse
or are you interacting with somebody
else in the metaverse then taking your
headphone phone off and having an
independent experience with this person
that's what i don't think they're
actually next i mean if you run into
someone in the metaverse
you're people physically in the room
with you it's like you're gonna go to
the eiffel tower and you can look up and
see the place and see the people that
are visiting right there and whatever
and then you take your thing off and
you're in your bed is it just earth like
the metaverse is earth like there's
eiffel tower there's new york there's
not like
there's not like what would i spend a
whole day with a [ __ ] headset on
going to lax in my headset getting on a
flight and during a five hour ride
before does it take that long verse to
get to no
it's it's it's at least teleport there
it's the same thing okay so okay we
learned something today there's
teleportation in the middle it's the
same thing as doing this on your screen
all day you know you're like
you know but now you
all right we're getting the light we got
to wrap up yeah we're getting the light
and this is where this is longer than we
basically oh my gosh
i didn't give a [ __ ]
i've enjoyed the [ __ ] out of this man i
really i really have enjoyed the [ __ ]
out of this you know what man i think at
the end of the day with this whole
celebrity thing is we're going into this
new age where like i don't even know
what how to define a celebrity
necessarily anymore uh you know you you
you
trigger a lot of nostalgia for a lot of
people and i think i do the same thing
yeah so you know when my girl hit me up
and she was like yo stevo wants you on
on on his podcast you know it was like
an instant yes and i just i just kind of
hope that i'm able to kind of like
be that myself a little bit too where i
hope people say hey wait i want you on
this podcast
it's like it's an instant yes yeah all
right
just know that we're instant yeses i
think bro i love that i love it i i
appreciate it so much and and we're
clearly promoting it's purple
so where do we send people to get it so
just go to itspurple.com um or um at
purple urkel on on instagram and then
just click the link in the bio and all
our stores are always listed right there
um in la i know tropicana is uh in oc
and uh the artist tree is one of my
favorite stores out here on
in west hollywood on santa monica
boulevard uh there's some really like
you know apple level type stores out
there right now wow super techy you know
really glad that's what it's like i'm
like i refuse to let anybody call this
the weed business if you haven't got
into one of these stores man and you're
right it's a trip and you see what it is
wait until the lounges come out we got
lounges coming in in west hollywood um
west hollywood's about to take over um
what amsterdam used to be and take it to
a whole nother level [ __ ] wow i'll buy
that in the middle
you're a full dog
i'll [ __ ] in the better verse
download i'll get high as [ __ ]
dad that's epic i was gonna say i called
it the weird game
we'll let it slide
this time and um yeah and so other than
that like uh
you got instagram yeah yeah
angela white um i'm in um i'm an adam
sandler's movie hustle coming out next
summer
um there's still a lot of film works
that are in the uh that are in the
pipeline um you just those happen so
slow
and the metaverse speed says you got to
be talking about what you're doing right
now right that it was like yo it takes
like you know i get a year and two years
freaking edit this stuff and then you
get to talk about it yeah before you go
who was the better basketball player you
were clooney i used to get his ass dog
come
will say this on
i will say but i will say this though i
always respectful of mr lake como always
yeah um his uh his horse game was out of
this world you could not beat georgia
horse though okay
he's got the shot yeah george was doing
it you remember those those mcdonald's
commercials where it was like you know
off the backboard off the side off the
carpet for sure that's how george plays
okay and he's good at it good right on
all right well dude i'm stuck on there
anything else we can plug for you we
don't need a blood crab man we having a
good time man
happy holidays christmas happy holidays
go listen to some black christmas music
and uh and don't feel bad about calling
it christmas man you know what i'm
saying dad i love it man thank you all
right yeah
what can we say about jaleel white man
just a good dude
like ma'am i'd like to think that i'm
gonna hang out with him in the future
really enjoyed that and as always man
you guys who stick around to the very
end of the podcast you're what it's all
about i bow to you with my gratitude my
glorious street team
and there's really nothing else to say
except
thank you
[ __ ] yeah and thanks jaleel white that
was killer